>> Sean: THANK YOU, AND MOVE
ON AND NOW, MULTIPLE
INVESTIGATIONS UNDER WACOM
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR IS WORKING
HARD FOR THE GOVERNMENT
BUREAUCRACY TO FIX THIS MESS AND
THOSE WHO TRIED TO RIG THE
RUSSIAN PEER ACTION.
-- THOSE WHO WOULD TRY TO RAKE
WITH RUSSIAN LIES A PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
THOSE THAT TRY TO BUDGET AN END
SEEING -- AND SEAT UNDULY
ELECTED PRESIDENT.
THE SAME FOR HOUSE DEMOCRATS
CLEARLY MORE INTERESTED IN THE
POLITICAL CIRCUS DESIGNED TO
SMEAR THE PRESIDENT ALL IN
ADVANCE OF THE 2020 ELECTION.
THERE YOU HAVE HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE JERRY NADLER SET TO
COLD JOHN DEAN OF WATERGATE FAME
TO TESTIFY IN THE MUELLER
REPORT.
JOHN DEAN, THE STAR AND WITNESS
IN RICHARD NIXON'S WATERGATE
SCANDAL.
THAT WAS 47 YEARS AGO.
HE HAS ABSOLUTELY NOTHING, ZERO,
TO OFFER AS IT RELATES TO THE
MUELLER REPORT.
OR FRANKLY, ANY OF THE ISSUES AT
HAND HERE.
NOTHING.
HE HAS NO EXPERTISE ON RUSSIAN
ELECTION HACKING.
BUT DEAN ONLY NOW WORKS FOR FAKE
NEWS CNN AS A PROFESSIONAL TRUMP
HAIDER.
24/7, HATE, RAGE PSYCHOSIS.
JERRY NADLER FIGURES O NOBODY
MORE PERFECT LET'S ROLL HIM OUT
FOR ANOTHER TRUMP GROUND OF
TRUMP BASHING EVEN THOUGH HE HAS
NO RELEVANCE TO THE CASE AND BY
THE WACOM IF YOU ARE LIKE
MOST AMERICANS AND YOU DON'T
WATCH FAKE NEWS CNN OR
CONSPIRACY CNN -- MSNBC.
THE GREAT KNOWLEDGE, THE GREAT
OBJECTIVE ANALYSIS OF JERRY
NADLER STAR WITNESS AND WHAT HE
WILL BRING TO CAPITOL HILL AND
THE CIRCUS HE HAS THROWN OVER
THERE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> TRUMP IS SHOWING THE STYLE.
TRUMP IS NIXON ON STEROIDS AND
STILTS.
IF I HAD TO CHANNEL LITTLE
RICHARD NIXON COME I THINK HE
WOULD TELL THIS PRESIDENT HE IS
GOING TO FAR.
THIS IS THE SORT OF STUFF --
THIS IS WHAT AN AUTOCRAT DOES.
HE IS THINKING LIKE PUTIN WOULD
THINK.
>> Sean: SO WHY WOULD JERRY
NADLER PROMOTE AN OBVIOUSLY
ANGRY, WASHED UP FAR LEFT
EXTREME LEFTIST CNN HACK TO
PERFORM IN FRONT OF HIS PARTISAN
CIRCUS?
AND TELL SHIFT, ADAM SCHIFF TO
LIE THROUGH HIS TEA PER USUAL
AND THE COWARDLY ADAM SHIP
CALLED WILLIAM BARR THE SECOND
MOST DANGEROUS MAN IN THE
COUNTRY.
REALLY?
TAKE A LOOK.
AND SO WE FIND OURSELVES I THINK
FOR THE FIRST TIME WITH AN
ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO REALLY IS
THE PRESIDENT'S DEFENSE LEADER
AND SPOKESPERSON.
AND WHO IS QUITE AT IT.
AND HAS THE VENEER OF
RESPECTABILITY TO CAMOUFLAGE
WHAT HE'S DOING.
HE IS NOT THE SOPHIST THAT
GIULIANI IS BUT MUCH MORE
DANGEROUS.
AND I THINK HE IS THE SECOND
MOST DANGEROUS MAN IN THE
COUNTRY FOR THAT REASON.
>> Sean: MOST DANGEROUS PLACE
IN THE COUNTRY IS BEING BETWEEN
THE COWARDLY ADAM SHIP OR A
MICROPHONE OR A CAMERA BECAUSE
HE'S OBSESSED WITH SEEING HIMSEF
HE'S OBSESSED WITH SEEING HIMSEA
HE'S OBSESSED WITH SEEING HIMSED
HEARING HIMSELF.
IT IS THIS KIND OF BASELESS
VITRIOL AND NOTHING NEW BECAUSE
FOR YEARS THE COWARDLY ADAM
SCHIFF PROMOTING LIE AFTER LIE,
TRUMP RUSSIA CONSPIRACY THEORIES
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
HE HAS LIED MORE THAN ANY OTHER
SINGLE MEMBER OF CONGRESS WHICH
SAYS A LOT ABOUT HIM.
WE HAVE INVITED HIM FOR A FULL
HOUR ON THIS TV SHOW.
I HAVE OFFERED HIM THREE HOURS
COMPLETE ON MY RADIO PROGRAM,
616 STATIONS SO HE CAN DEFEND
HIS RECKLESS RHETORIC, FOUR
HOURS OF AIR TIME WITH ME.
I HAVE A DOSSIER ON EVERYTHING
HE HAS EVER SAID.
LIKE ALL THESE OTHER LYING
DEMOCRATS, HE REFUSES TO COME ON
BECAUSE SCHIFF IS NOT ONLY A
COWARD BUT HE'S A LIAR AND HE
KNOWS HE'S A LIAR.
INSTEAD OF DEFENDING HIMSELF HE
WILL DOUBLE DOWN ON CERTAIN LIES
THAT GET MORE ABSURD EVERY DAY.
MAYBE HE WILL INVITE FELLOW
CONSPIRACY THEORIST RACHEL
MADDOW TO THE HILL.
TWO BIGGEST LAYERS IN THE
COUNTRY TOGETHER IN ONE PLACE AT
LAST.
CNN TAUNTING CAN TESTIFY AND HAS
NOTHING TO OFFER ANYTHING AT
THIS POINT AS POSSIBLE BUT OF
COURSE, RACHEL MADDOW CAN USE
THE PUBLICITY BECAUSE HER
RATINGS AS WELL CNN RATINGS HAVE
TAKEN A DIVE SINCE LIES IN
CONSPIRACY THEORIES TWO PLUS
YEARS HAVE BEEN EXPOSED.
NOW THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NO
LONGER TRUST AND BC CHIEF
CONSPIRACISTS THEORIST.
BY THE WAY, TOM BROKAW -- TOM
BROKAW, ARE YOU PART OF THIS?
TAKE A LOOK.
WE ARE ABOUT TO FIND OUT THE NEW
PRESIDENT OF OUR COUNTRY WILL DO
WHAT HE WANTS.
>> WE HAVEN'T HAD TO RECKON WITH
THE POSSIBILITY HAVE SOMEONE HAS
ASCENDED TO THE PRESIDENCY OF
THE UNITED STATES TO SERVE THE
INTEREST OF ANOTHER COUNTRY
RATHER THAN OUR OWN.
WHAT IS THE CORRECTIVE TO THAT?
HOW DO YOU REMEDY THAT?
THESE ARE NO LONGER HYPOTHETICAL
QUESTIONS.
THIS IS WHERE WE ARE.
THE PRESIDENCY IS EFFECTIVELY A
RUSSIAN UP JUST LIKE NEGATIVE 5E
RUSSIAN UP JUST LIKE NEGATIVE 5R
RUSSIAN UP JUST LIKE NEGATIVE 5S
RUSSIAN UP JUST LIKE NEGATIVE 5A
RUSSIAN UP JUST LIKE NEGATIVE 5D
RUSSIAN UP JUST LIKE NEGATIVE 5T
RUSSIAN UP JUST LIKE NEGATIVE 5E
RUSSIAN UP JUST LIKE NEGATIVE 5D
RUSSIAN UP JUST LIKE NEGATIVE 5K
RUSSIAN UP JUST LIKE NEGATIVE 5T
RUSSIAN UP JUST LIKE NEGATIVE 5S
RUSSIAN UP JUST LIKE NEGATIVE 5R
RUSSIAN UP JUST LIKE NEGATIVE 5G
RUSSIAN UP JUST LIKE NEGATIVE 5T
NOW.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF RUSSIA
KILLED THE POWER IN FARGO TODAY?
>> Sean: ANYWAY, SADLY RACHEL
MADDOW DILUTION IS NOT UNCOMMON
IN SO-CALLED MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
IN OTHER WORDS 99% OF THE MEDIA
THAT SPENT TWO YEARS LYING AGAIN
THAT SPENT TWO YEARS LYING AGAIA
THAT SPENT TWO YEARS LYING AGAID
THAT SPENT TWO YEARS LYING AGAIN
THAT SPENT TWO YEARS LYING AGAIH
THAT SPENT TWO YEARS LYING AGAIE
THAT SPENT TWO YEARS LYING AGAIA
THAT SPENT TWO YEARS LYING AGAII
THAT SPENT TWO YEARS LYING AGAIN
PEOPLE, SMEARING, LYING,
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, FAKE NEWS,
YOU NAME IT, THEY DOMINATE
COVERAGE ON THE THREE NETWORKS.
"WASHINGTON POST,"
"NEW YORK TIMES," CNN, MSNBC AND
ANY OTHER BASIC OUTLET OUT
THERE.
OF COURSE, THEY ARE MERELY DOING
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S BIDDING
AS THEY WORK IN UNISON, AND THEY
ARE ONLY BUT IT IS AN EXTENSION
OF ALL DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST.
THAT IS WHY THE MEDIA HAS RAMPED
UP IMPEACHMENT HYSTERIA AFTER
MUELLER'S NINE MINUTE PUBLIC
DIATRIBE DISASTER LAST WEEK
WHICH RESULTED IN A COMPLETE
DETRACTION AND COMPLETE
CLARIFICATION HOURS LATER.
THOSE NINE AND A HALF MINUTES
CONTRADICTED EVERYTHING HE HAD
BEEN SAYING UP TO THAT POINT.
IN THE END, AS I HAVE BEEN
SAYING, MUELLER IS DONE AND THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION IS OVER,
FINISHED CONFIRMED BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THE PRESIDENT IS GUILTY OF THE
ROPE CRIMES.
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION.
NO CONSPIRACY WITH RUSSIA.
AND THERE WAS NONE, ZERO,
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
BUT THE MEDIA, THEY CAN'T HELP
THEMSELVES AFTER TWO YEARS OF
LYING, PERHAPS THEY HAVE
CONVINCED THEMSELVES THEY ARE
LIES IN CONSPIRACY THEORIES ARE
TRUE.
THEY ARE STILL BEGGING FOR
IMPEACHMENT.
FOR WHAT REASON?
THEY CANNOT OFFER ONE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> MOUNTING PRESSURE AND CLOSE
TO CALL FOR IMPEACHMENT AFTER
ROBERT MUELLER BREAKS HIS
TWO-YEAR SILENCE.
IF THE HOUSE LEADERSHIP DOESN'T
HEAR THE HEARINGS NOW, IT WILL
BE HARD TO SEE THEM DOING IT IN
THE MONTHS AHEAD.
AGAIN, NOW OR NEVER.
>> WE SEEM TO BE MOVING TO A
PLACE IMPEACHMENT MAY BE
INEVITABLE, BUT THE DAM SEEMS TO
BE BREAKING WIDE OPEN.
WHAT HE IS SAYING CONGRESS HAS A
JOB TO DO.
>> ALMOST A JEOPARDY QUESTION
THE WAY ROBERT MUELLER PUT IT
YESTERDAY.
THERE IS A PROCESS OTHER THAN
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM TO
CHARGE THE SITTING PRESIDENT.
WHAT IS THE ANSWER?
THE ANSWER IS IMPEACHMENT.
>> Sean: SO YOU HAVE THE MEDIA
MOB, DEMOCRATS DEEP STATE ELITES
ALL WANT THE SAME THING, GET RID
OF DONALD TRUMP AND THEY THINK